c'est pas possible er allez ça c'est une
erreur on va passer maintenant au
témoins du jour on va recevoir Vincent
ça fait beaucoup parler C histoir cet
agriculteur qui élève des vaches
dansloise il a été condamné à payer plus
de 100000 € de dommage intérêt à ses
voisins la raison ses voisins sont plein
du bruit des vaches et de leur odeur
visiblement pas habitué à la campagne
Vincent a tout essayé pour réduire les
nuisances mais cela n'a pas suffi
aujourd'hui il risque de tout pe tout
pe tout peur va pas y arriver
aujourd'hui
ah ouais c'est triste sera avec nous
dans un instantant bon allez
allez les conflits de voisinage à la
campagne semblent être de plus en plus
fréquents ces nouveaux arrivants qui se
plaignent du champ du coq ou du fumier
qui sent trop fort et alors qu'une
députée Renaissance veut protéger les
ouvriers agricoles via une nouvelle loi
de nombreux agriculteurs sont
aujourd'hui poursuivis pour troubles
anormaux du voisinage parmi eux Vincent
qui a été condamné à verser une somme
conséquente à ses voisins gêné par l'EUR
le bruit et le meuglement de ces animaux
106000 € de dommage intérêt alors un
agriculteur condamné à payer 106000 € à
ses voisin à cause de l'odeur et du
bruit de ses vaches il s'exprime ce soir
dans
TPMP merci merci Vincent ne parlez pas à
Jean-Michel non mais merci vin en tout
cas merci d'être avec nous le sujet est
important et on est content de vous
avoir par qu'on espère qu'on va on va
vous sauver on va réussir à faire
quelque chose vous êtes agriculteur
éleveur à saint-auas ambbré à côté de
beauvet dans l'Oise agriculteur depuis
combien de temps moi je me suis installé
à l'âge de 21 ans d'accord euh j'en ai
34 aujourd'hui donc je me suis installé
en 2009 et j'ai repris la ferme familiel
c'est la 4e génération vous élevez des
vaches uniquement oui oui vous en avez
combien on a 80 vaches tétièr
et puis bah forcément on garde les
élèves les petits veau et cetera donc un
total de 250 bêtes au total alors euh
votre établissement il il a été
construit dans les normes c'est pour ça
qu'on a dû reconstruire en 2010 quand je
me suis installé pour répondre aux
normes européennes d'accord donc on a
demandé un permis de construire qui nous
a été accordé on avait pas de terrain à
plus de 100 m des habitations donc on a
demandé une dérogation de distance pour
déroger à cette règle et être à moins de
100 m qui nous a été également accordé
donc suite à ça on a construit ce
bâtiment et une fois le bâtiment
construit les riverins bah ont attaqué
avant même qu'il y ait des bêtes dedans
de toute façon d'accord donc là tout est
enorme tout est tout est
nickel ça c'est ça on a tout norme on a
mêmeè très moderne paraî-il on a essayé
d'aller plus loin dans la démarche on
récupère toutes nos autres pluies on les
réutilise pour l'alimentation des bêtes
c'est ça euh on avait essayé d'installer
tout ce qui était salle de traite et
cetera avec une démarche de réduction
électronique pour pour limiter la
consommation pour limiter de 80 % le
bruit aussi pour justement sachant qu'on
était proche des habitations et puis un
bâtiment bah comme vous voyez totalement
en bois
ouais qui s'inscrit dans dans l'écologie
quoi mais proche c'est combien de mètres
je voulais savoir proche c'est combien
de mètres maison à 30 m 30 m d'accord
c'est pas c'est tout près combien de vos
voisins sont pleins donc il y a si
rivrins qui sont pleins si voisins donc
l'odeur l'odeur et le bruit c'est ça
d'accord il se plent donc ils disent
quoi que c'est ils savait ils savait que
vous étiez là non donc il y avait une
ferme qui était là ouais on a
reconstruit ce bâtiment là bah proche de
leur terrain en fait et c'est ce qui
leur a posé problème
alors ce sont des voisins avec qui vous
entendiez bien avec eux au départ ou pas
du tout on avait pas spécialement de
relation avec quand est croisé on dire
bonjour mais rien de c'est des odeurs
courantes qu'on qu'on à la campagne ou
bien c'est vraiment s' y a du vent
vraiment non pour le coup on a choisi
donc les les animaux sont uniquement sur
de la paille il y a pas de raclage de
lisier il y a pas de donc il y a pas de
stockage de fumier sur la ferme non plus
c'est vraiment les animaux sont que sur
de la paille donc bien évidemment le
jour on nettoie le bâtiment ce qui va
arriver grosso modo une fois par mois
euh bah ça peut générer une petite odeur
en effet suffit que les vent porte vers
les maisons bah les maisons peuvent
sentir mais ils vous ont jamais appelé
prévenu en vous disant ça commence à non
ça a démarré directement donc la
première procédure c'était d'attaquer la
mairie pour demander l'annulation du
permis de construire d'accord et il y a
eu une tentative à ce moment-là de de
médiation d'expliquer un petit peu
justement pourquoi ce bâtiment é avit
reconstruit euh quelle nécessité il y
avait et cetera et du coup tout le
village était invité dans la salle des
fêtes de la mairie avec des personnes
qui étaient venu donc les services
vétérinaires d'autres agriculteur et
cetera pour essayer d'expliquer un petit
peu la démarche et j'avais souvenir
d'avoir échangé avec ses voisins et l'un
me dit non mais le bâtiment il est
magnifique il est il est bien conçu il
est beau les animaux sont bien dedans
mais pas derrière chez moi oua d'accord
alors euh il y a jamais eu aucune
médiation donc direct ça a été au procès
direct ça a été du coup la seule fois où
ça a été bah tenté de de limiter cette
démarche et puis après après une fois
judiciaire il y a eu une tentative de
médiation d'accord alors aujourd'hui
vous avez été condamné en première
instance à payé 106000 € de dommage
d'intérêt à vos
voisins est-ce que vous attendiez une
telle
condamnationnorme c'est 106000 € comment
vous allez faire pour payer non on
s'attendait pas du tout à une
condannation bah aussi conséquente je
pense que c'est quand même pas des
choses qu'on qu'on voit tous les jours
on n pas tué quelqu'un volontairement on
n pas je veux dire voilà on a juste
essayé de vouloir
je me suis installé on m'a dit bah faut
faut vous mettre en norme c'est c'est
comme ça so vous les faites soit vous
arrêtez l'élevage on est une ferme qui
est à 90 % d'élevage donc bien
évidemment on s'est mis au norme on a
respecté et puis on a même été plus loin
que les obligation on a voulu justement
faire au
mieux sachant qu'on était proche des
habitations on s'est dit il faut qu'on
intègre le bâtiment au lieu où il est en
fait et être condamné derrière comme ça
non c'est dur comment justifie justement
cette condamn la nation alors que vous
êtes dans les clous vous êtes dans les
normes qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui a été
dit dans le parce qu'aujourd'hui un
trouble anormal de voisinage c'est vous
avez pas besoin de ne pas être dans les
normes justement vous pouvez respecter
toutes les règles c'est même ce que le
juge est venu dire c'est toutes les
règles sont respectées l'exploitation
est très biené mais par sa proximité des
habitations
enjre forcément des nuisances excessives
selon le
juge en fait monsieur il a été condamné
en 2018 condamné encore en 2022 en appel
et il se pourvoit cassation mais cyil le
problème de la cassation c'est que c'est
pas suspensif il est obligé de trouver
la Somme et donc là il est en train de
se commentou alors il est en train de se
ruiné il y a la région il a est-ce que
vous avez déjà pensé à faire des vidéos
TikTok quoi faire quoi des vidéos sur
TikTok euh non parce que justement vous
pourrez faire des vidéos et c'est un
sujet qu'on voit pas trop les vaches et
tout donc je pense ça peut
marcher mais c'est vrai c'est
vrai pour alimenter une cagnotte pour
non non pour faire des vidéos sur TikTok
parce que quand tu fais des vidéos de
plus d'une minute tu es payé
ouis ou mais
pour qui esttn c'est condamn à payer000
€ ça va pas faire disparaître l'odeur
donc ils ont quoi il gagner les
voisin dire que sur CIV ont vendu le
maison déménager plus les nouveaux
arrivants n'ont jamais partter plaines
quoi que ce soit ils vivent leur vie
tranquillement sont heureux d'être là
donc les trois qui sont partis ils ont
quand même touché les dommag intért sont
plus làtion ne s'éteint pas alors qu'ils
sont plus là c'est ça c'est n'importe
c'est le dommage subi pendant le temps
où c'est N et ils sont arrivés avant ou
après vous euh non non avant après nous
ah les voisins sont arrivés a aprè nous
mais avant qu'on construise le bâtiment
rapoché le bâtiment ça je comprends pas
parce que lorsqu'ils ont acheté ils ont
acheté en toute connaissance de cause
ils sont installés oui mais eux te
disent qu'il y avait une exploitation
qui était là ok mais il y avait pas ce
bâtiment btim par le bâtiment le
bâtiment qu'on a reconstruit il est à 10
m des anciens ouais mais on va plus quoi
on se rapproche un peu de leur terrain
de ces fameuses maisons et donc pour eux
euh c'est au moment où le bâtiment été
créé
que l'occasion était là d'attaquer puis
qu'il y avait une nouvelle
construction parce que c'est vrai moi je
suis d'accord avec le monsieur il faut
qu'il a ses vaches faut qu'il travaille
mais on a notre pavillon à moins de 30 m
tu as 80 vaches qui font après manger tu
as le vent qui arrive chez toi tu es
dans ton barbecue tuas il y a l'odeur
les gars
quand ils se sont installés nveau
bâtiment 10 m de différence alors 10
mur diff c'est comme les maisons qui
sont à
côté c'est pas une question d'aller mais
moi j'habite à la campagne me dis pas je
va à la campagne j'habite moi à la
campagne je suis jeis en fout de l'odeur
des vaches sauf que si un mec rapproche
sa ferme de de ma salle à manger ou de
mon barbe sa ferme de mon barbecue je
dire je fais l'avocat du DI légal le mec
qui lu a dit c'est légal il habite pas
dans le pavillon où ça s'est rapproché
me mais est-ce qu'on peut avoir un peu
de respect quand même pour les
agriculteurs on est bien content d'avoir
des vaches pour boire du lait et manger
de la viande et là on les défonce parce
qu'il y a une petite odeur de vaches de
temps en
temps
s'enter c'est débile Jean-Michel a
raison c'est pas parce que tu vas leur
donner 10000 € 20000 € 30000
€ aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous en êes où
alors donc là aujourd'hui on a déjà
réglé 6000 € pour pouvoir se pourvoir en
cassation c'est pas possible ça c'est
abusé donc on a eu la chance que la
région ha de France nous a fait un prê
préférentiel à tau préférentiel de 40000
€ et l'autre partie qui a été souscrit
sous prêt personnel près de la
B recondamné ou
bien si le pourvoie là n'aboutit pas on
doit retourner devant le tribunal de
grande instance de bvet qui lui va
statuer sur les aménagements possibles
au N du bâtiment donc soit là on a déjà
vu faire des proposition donc d'isoler
ce bâtiment de manière acoustique et
phonique de recréer une ventilation
artificielle parce que c'est les animaux
qui sontessous il faut que ça ventile ah
et donc on serait encore entre 100 et
150000 € d'investissement à
recréer et on ne sait pas si le juge va
retenir il peut aussier la démolition
faudra absolument vraiment que que ce
soit rejugé et que vous en sortiez parce
que c'est inadmissible franchement 100
6000 € sur pas le sens du jugement sent
merci d'êre venu nousir que vot
témoignage est important et on espère ça
va faire bouger les choses et on est à
fond derrière vous voilà et si il faut
faire venir il faut faire la vache je
viendrai faire avec avec plaisir d'ord
merci à vous ne lâchez rien et continuez
parce qu'on a besoin des agriculteurs on
les aime fort et on le dit tous les
jours c'est déjà très difficile d'être
agriculteur si en plus on leur met des
bâtons dans les roues c'est
insupportable et bravo pour ce que vous
faites et bravo pour pour votre métier
qui est essentiel et vraiment je je
voilà je dis on est à fond derrière les
agriculteurs il faut vraiment que ça
bouge pour eux aue leur mettre des
bâtons dans les roues il faudrait plutôt
les aider encore plus parce que c'est
très compliqué qu'est-ce que tu veux non
parce qu'il y a une députée Renaissance
qui veut faire voter une loi pour
justement qu' est plus ces procédures
parce qu'il y en a 500 environ en France
en ce
momentè espè ça va voter ça y est depuis
lundi est voté elle est passée donc elle
sera pas rétroac voilà voà ser pas
rétroactive maisou mais ça peut passer
avec la cassation ça peut passer j'y
crois j'y crois Vincent merci d'être
avec nous dans un instant on va parler
de Jade et Joy connaissez les filles de
Johnny ALID
au-delà de l'eau
différence tout de suite